Trascrizione: Matteo Maggiò
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Una delle mie passioni
è nuotare in acque libere:
e l'ho fatto anche qui, ieri sera,
nel vostro magnifico mare.
A ottobre è un mare caldo:
cinque gradi più caldo della media.
Piacevolissimo, naturalmente:
ma anche un campanello d'allarme
per il nostro pianeta.
Il 2022 è stato l'anno
più arido e caldo in Italia di sempre;
ed è stato, anche, l'anno in cui
la drammatica situazione in Ucraina
ci ricorda, ogni giorno,
quanto siamo vulnerabili alla geopolitica,
per il nostro accesso all'energia.
Quello dell'energia è un problema globale:
dobbiamo trovare una sorgente di energia
che sia pulita, sicura,
disponibile per tutti
e compatibile con lo sviluppo sostenibile.
Ovvero, che permetta
un benessere per tutti
senza mettere un'ipoteca
sul futuro del nostro pianeta.
Che cosa possiamo fare?
Non c'è dubbio che, nel futuro,
avremo una grande parte
del nostro fabbisogno
che sarà coperta
dalle energie rinnovabili;
e dobbiamo fare tutti in modo
che la loro efficienza venga aumentata:
quella dei pannelli solari,
quella delle centrali eoliche, a vento.
Ma è anche vero che le rinnovabili,
da sole, non ce la possono fare,
perché sono intrinsecamente intermittenti;
non c'è sempre il sole;
non c'è sempre vento,
ci sono le stagioni, il giorno,
la notte, le nuvole.
Quindi, l'energia che esse producono
deve essere immagazzinata,
deve essere stoccata da qualche parte.
E lo stoccaggio dell'energia
è un problema molto dispendioso,
sia dal punto di vista economico
che da quello ambientale.
C'è bisogno di un'energia di base
che aiuti, che spalleggi le rinnovabili,
che fornisca energia come, dove
e quando ne abbiamo bisogno.
Quasi tutti i paesi
hanno realizzato questa necessità:
alcuni vi fanno fronte costruendo, ancora,
centrali basate sull'energia fossile,
sui combustibili fossili.
Sappiamo che oggi usiamo
più dell'80% dei combustibili
sotto forma di combustibili fossili.
Il Sole li ha prodotti
su decine di milioni di anni,
tramite il suo irraggiamento
e tramite i processi
geologici sulla Terra.
Noi ce li stiamo, letteralmente, bruciando
su decine di anni.
Quindi, è chiaro che non possiamo
continuare a usarli:
finiranno.
Ma appunto, l'urgenza
di trovare alternative -
come le rinnovabili -
viene non solo dalla geopolitica,
ma naturalmente dal clima.
Questo bruciare, che noi facciamo,
non fa che produrre gas a effetto serra,
quindi contribuire
al riscaldamento globale.
Quindi, quest'idea dei Paesi,
come la Germania,
di costruire centrali
a combustibile fossile,
per aiutare le rinnovabili,
forse non è proprio
completamente sostenibile.
Altri Paesi, come la Francia,
per questa energia di base
di cui abbiamo bisogno
usano l'energia nucleare
convenzionale, da fissione,
con i suoi pro e i suoi contro.
Ci sono altre possibilità?
Abbiamo alternative, per avere energie
che siano disponibili per tutti,
e senza rischi per il pianeta?
Dobbiamo pensarci molto bene,
dobbiamo pensarci
prima che sia troppo tardi.
E a pensarci prima,
mi viene in mente un personaggio
studiato ai tempi lontani del liceo,
"colui che pensa prima": Prometeo.
Vi ricordate di Prometeo,
il titano amico
dell'umanità e del progresso,
che ruba il fuoco agli dei
per darlo agli uomini?
Perché non pensiamo come Prometeo?
Perché non andiamo a rubare
il fuoco agli dèi,
per portarlo sulla terra?
Cos'è il fuoco degli dèi?
Il sole, le stelle.
Il Sole è la nostra stella:
e tutta l'energia ci viene,
direttamente o indirettamente, dal Sole.
Circa un centinaio di anni fa
abbiamo capito come funziona il Sole,
come funzionano tutte le stelle:
funzionano secondo il principio
della fusione nucleare.
Mettono insieme dei piccolissimi nuclei,
delle piccolissime particelle,
per formare ancora nuclei
relativamente piccoli,
e rilasciare dell'energia.
I nuclei che formano questa reazione,
che è la reazione di fusione,
all'inizio sono un po' più pesanti:
si è persa della massa quando, alla fine,
hanno fornito la reazione.
Questa massa, che si è persa,
si è trasformata in energia:
Come diceva Einstein,
massa ed energia sono la stessa cosa:
sono equivalenti.
A partire dall'idrogeno, si forma l'elio;
e via via, tutti gli altri elementi.
È così che funzionano le stelle,
ma è anche così che si è formato
tutto l'universo.
Al contrario dell'energia di fissione,
l'energia nucleare convenzionale,
che si basa sullo spaccare
dei nuclei grandi, complessi, radioattivi;
e tramite processi di reazione a catena,
spaccarne ancora altri,
sempre complessi, sempre radioattivi -
questa della fusione è un'energia pulita:
non ha scorie radioattive.
È un'energia sicura,
perché non ha processi
di reazione a catena
di cui si potrebbe perdere il controllo.
E la densità di energia, nel combustibile,
è gigantesca,
tale per cui il combustibile -
che si trova in parte in natura,
in parte le forniamo noi stessi
tramite i prodotti
delle reazioni nucleari -
è praticamente illimitato.
Vi voglio dare un esempio:
prendiamo la mia città di origine, Milano.
Un milione e mezzo di abitanti,
diciamo due-tre volte Genova.
Uno stadio magnifico,
lo stadio di San Siro.
Voglio alimentare la città di Milano
per un anno di energia:
un anno.
Oggigiorno lo faccio
con combustibili fossili,
diciamo del carbone.
Per un anno l'energia per Milano,
bisogna riempire
tutto lo stadio di San Siro,
fino a terzo anello compreso:
80.000 posti, fino in cima, di carbone.
Immaginate quanti treni
devono venire a Milano, ogni anno.
Migliaia di treni carichi di carbone,
per l'energia di un anno.
Ora, non dico se, ma quando utilizzeremo
il combustibile di fusione nucleare
non avrò bisogno di treni,
non avrò bisogno neanche
di un'automobile, per portarlo:
avrò bisogno, semplicemente,
del rimorchio della mia bicicletta.
L'energia sarà custodita
in una sacca, per un anno,
per un milione e mezzo di persone.
Voi direte: "Fantastico!
Ma perché non l'abbiamo ancora?
Cosa stiamo aspettando?"
Ci stiamo arrivando.
Ci stiamo arrivando ma non è mica facile,
fare una stella sulla Terra.
Bisogna, prima di tutto,
fare in modo che questi nuclei -
che dicevo, si devono fondere -
si avvicinino abbastanza
gli uni agli altri:
bisogna farli scontrare
ad altissima velocità.
Velocità disordinata,
a livello microscopico.
E chi dice: "Velocità
disordinata microscopica",
dice "alta temperatura".
Voi penserete: uh, centinaia di gradi.
No: vi sto parlando di decine,
centinaia di milioni di gradi.
Può esistere una materia,
a questa temperatura?
Sì, può esistere: ma non negli stati
che abbiamo l'abitudine di conoscere
tutti i giorni sulla terra.
Non nello stato solido,
non nello stato liquido;
e neanche in quello gassoso,
perché tutte le molecole e tutti gli atomi
sarebbero dissolti, spaccati,
divisi fra nuclei ed elettroni.
Si crea una specie di "zuppa"
di particelle cariche
che hanno voglia di andare
da tutte le parti,
che si chiama il plasma,
il quarto stato della materia.
Uno Stato che ci sembra molto esotico:
e lo è, sulla Terra.
Ma in realtà, tutto l'universo,
praticamente tutto l'universo a noi noto,
è in stato di plasma;
e lo sono in particolare le stelle,
di cui noi vogliamo fare
delle piccole copie sulla terra
per tirarne dell'energia,
come moderni Prometei,
quando e dove ne abbiamo bisogno.
Allora dobbiamo portare il plasma
a queste temperature di milioni,
decine, centinaia di milioni di gradi.
E come fare?
Pensiamo alle nostre cucine.
Abbiamo dei forni a microonde,
onde elettromagnetiche:
potremmo usare quelle.
Noi abbiamo bisogno di una
piccolissima quantità di materia,
perché la densità di energia è enorme;
quindi prendiamo una piccolissima
quantità di materia,
una frazione di un minuscolo
cucchiaino di minestra,
e lo irraggiamo con l'equivalente
di migliaia di forni a microonde.
Cosa succede a questa
piccolissima frazione
di un cucchiaino di minestra?
Diventa più calda del centro del Sole,
e dà luogo a reazioni di fusione.
Lo facciamo tutti i giorni,
nei nostri esperimenti.
Però le stelle, in particolare il Sole,
hanno un enorme vantaggio,
rispetto a noi: sono grandi.
Essere grandi vuol dire avere
una grande massa,
quindi vuol dire tenere a sé,
tenere insieme questo plasma
che scapperebbe da tutte le parti,
per la forza di gravitazione.
Noi non possiamo permetterci
di fare una stella sulla Terra
che sia più grande della Terra stessa.
Dobbiamo essere più furbi:
però, anche in questo caso,
vediamo cosa fa la natura,
e vediamo questa immagine.
C'è il Sole, col suo plasma
che scappa un po' da tutte le parti,
anche se la gravità
cerca di tenerlo insieme;
poi c'è la terra che sarebbe immersa
in un mare di plasma, che ci brucerebbe.
In realtà, la Terra è protetta:
ma da che cosa è protetta?
È protetta da uno scudo, da una gabbia,
che è quella fatta
dal suo campo magnetico.
Sapete che la Terra
ha un campo magnetico, naturalmente,
come fosse una grande calamita,
Polo Nord e Polo Sud;
e questa gabbia
tiene il plasma all'esterno.
L'idea è: fare una gabbia,
ma metterci il plasma dentro,
evitare che lui esca,
in modo che lo possiamo tenere lì
e farlo fondere, ovvero avere
dell'energia pulita.
La gabbia che ha avuto più successo,
finora, si chiama Tokamak.
È un nome che suona russo,
ed è russo, infatti:
è stato inventato negli anni '50
del secolo scorso, in Russia;
e adesso è un'idea
che viene usata globalmente.
Ed è proprio attraverso una serie
di tokamak, di esperimenti,
e grazie al fatto che a partire dal 1958
la fusione è stata "declassificata" -
ovvero la si fa tutti insieme,
in collaborazione e in pace -
che abbiamo ottenuto
una serie di progressi
e una serie di risultati
molto, molto importanti.
Alla fine degli anni '90,
abbiamo ottenuto il record di potenza
di fusione sulla Terra
da una piccola "stella" in un Tokamak,
nel Regno Unito, vicino a Oxford.
E dico "noi abbiamo", perché eravamo
tutti noi europei, insieme.
Avevo la fortuna di essere
nella sala di controllo,
e di operare l'esperimento:
c'era la BBC, c'erano i media locali
che registravano le nostre voci,
accenti, lingue di ogni tipo -
compreso, probabilmente,
la conversazione che avevo
sul Campionato di serie A
con il mio vicino, ingegnere italiano.
Abbiamo ulteriormente studiato
questo problema:
e abbiamo, qualche mese fa,
battuto il nostro stesso record.
E l'abbiamo fatto in condizioni
ancora più vicine a quelle di un reattore.
E questo fatto di avere ottenuto
queste performance, questi record,
han convinto tutti noi del campo -
ma soprattutto, tutti i politici
che ci sostengono -
che ce la possiamo fare:
è possibile costruire
una stella sulla terra.
Ma, anche, che dobbiamo
farlo tutti insieme.
E difatti, il prossimo passo
è fatto da noi, tutti insieme.
E quando dico "noi tutti insieme",
in questo caso non dico solo noi europei
ma dico, praticamente,
più di metà del mondo.
L'Europa, in questo caso, ha sei partner:
la Russia; gli Stati Uniti d'America;
la Cina; la Corea; l'India;
il Giappone e la Cina.
Si tratta del progetto "ITER":
il progetto che dimostrerà,
una volta per tutte,
la fattibilità scientifica e tecnologica
della fusione sulla Terra.
Produrrà dieci volte più potenza -
questo piccolo plasma,
questa piccola stella -
di quella che noi gli inietteremo.
Questi sette partner lavorano insieme,
non soltanto fornendo
finanziamenti e personale,
ma anche fornendo
i propri componenti, pezzi:
più di un milione di pezzi,
nel puzzle più complicato
mai messo insieme dall'essere umano.
Facendo questo, ognuno dei partner,
ognuno degli Stati che partecipano
avranno la capacità, la tecnologia
di costruire il loro proprio
reattore a fusione.
Quando funzionerà,
la fusione non sarà un'energia
soggetta a ricatti di uno stato
rispetto a un altro,
non sarà soggetta
a colonizzazione dell'energia:
sarà per tutti.
È un progetto, infatti,
nato come progetto di pace
alla fine della guerra fredda,
[nelle] discussioni
fra Reagan e Gorbaciov.
ITER, però, è ancora
un esperimento scientifico.
Questo plasma, questa piccola stella,
e tutti i sistemi che lo circondano,
dobbiamo farli funzionare
in maniera affidabile,
non soltanto per un
esperimento scientifico.
Dobbiamo farli funzionare
per tanti anni, per decenni.
Per fare questo,
abbiamo ancora alcune sfide
scientifiche e tecnologiche
da affrontare e da vincere.
Dobbiamo controllare ancora meglio
questo plasma che scappa
da tutte le parti;
i suoi avvenimenti un pochino violenti,
quando c'è una specie di eruzione;
dobbiamo fare dei magneti
ancora più efficienti.
Pensate che questi magneti sono mantenuti,
praticamente, allo zero assoluto,
a qualche centimetro dal posto
più caldo dell'universo.
Il posto più freddo dell'universo,
a qualche centimetro dal più caldo.
E noi lo facciamo in laboratorio.
I materiali che contengono questa stella,
la "bottiglia" entro la quale
questa stella è contenuta,
immaginate che devono sottoporsi
a carichi termici giganteschi.
L'unica cosa che mi viene
in mente, come confronto,
è quello con un veicolo spaziale
che deve partire dalla Terra
e andare nello spazio.
I suoi motori sono sottoposti
a dei carichi termici giganteschi,
come quelli cui dobbiamo
far fronte noi nel reattore.
Solo che questo dura
qualche decina di secondi,
qualche minuto, per il razzo;
per noi, deve durare decenni.
Ognuno di questi problemi sta trovando
una soluzione scientifica e tecnologica,
e quello che resta da fare
è di metterli tutti insieme.
Ed è l'ultima tappa che ci rimane,
prima di aver vinto
la sfida della fusione.
Per metterli tutti insieme,
noi stiamo già lavorando al progetto,
che è in parte in parallelo a ITER
e in parte seguirà ITER;
e che noi in Europa chiamiamo DEMO,
per "reattori di dimostrazione".
DEMO dimostrerà che è possibile
far funzionare la stella.
Non solo come esperimento scientifico -
che è interessantissimo,
ma non interessa la società
per le applicazioni,
per far funzionare città e ospedali -
ma come centrale elettrica
di produzione di energia
che produca molta più energia elettrica
di quella che consuma;
e che lo faccia per decenni,
in maniera affidabile,
e ad un costo che sia competitivo.
L'orizzonte temporale di DEMO,
visto da noi europei,
è a metà di questo secolo;
anche se io sono assolutamente convinto
che riusciremo ad accelerare,
perché l'urgenza di avere
una fonte di energia pulita
è enorme, ed è percepita da tutti;
e la nostra capacità di assorbire
innovazione intorno a noi
è in continuo miglioramento.
Sono tempi lunghi,
ma sono tempi necessari:
è come costruire una cattedrale.
È un processo che va
da generazione a generazione,
transgenerazionale.
Mai come oggi, però, io sono convinto
che il sogno di realizzare
una stella sulla terra si avvererà.
ITER è già quasi costruito;
siamo già sulla buona strada per DEMO.
Il sogno si sta avverando.
Alla fine di questo percorso,
avremo vinto una sfida epocale:
una sfida epocale
per il futuro energetico
del nostro pianeta,
ma anche per il futuro
di tutti noi insieme.
Una sfida scientifica, e tecnologica;
ma anche una sfida umana,
che sarà stata affrontata, e vinta,
perché siamo stati capaci di farla:
insieme;
in collaborazione;
coesi
ed in pace.
Non uno, non dieci, non cento:
mille Prometei moderni,
che lavorano per le generazioni a venire
e che hanno adottato il motto
che i nativi americani ripetono sempre:
"Noi non abbiamo ereditato
il nostro pianeta dai nostri antenati:
noi l'abbiamo preso a prestito
dai nostri figli".
Grazie.
(Applausi)